do you think you're good at managing
people very what makes you good at that
empathy the reason i think i've led well
my whole career is empathy comes really
natural to me i on the other hand always
say i work for them why would they even
work here they've got options they're
doing a poor job my brain goes into not
they suck my brain goes to i hope their
family's okay maybe they're sucking at
work because something bad empathy is
very very natural to me thus i think i'm
a good leader because i always think
what's in it for them and then i'll get
to me and i think if you do that for
everybody you find yourself in a very
powerful place i always think about it
as 5149 if i can give at least 51 of the
value of this relationship me and every
individual person on earth well then i'm
gonna know what to do with my 49. so i
think about that a lot and i think most
people are like i gotta get 80. yeah
like what what are they doing for me it
comes from ego and insecurity
entitlement